We become very used to turning on our
computer wherever we happen to be and it
automatically gets an IP address. This
might be on our local network at home.
It might be in a coffee shop or a hotel
or anywhere else we might happen to go.
Our computers are able to receive this
automatic IP addressing through DHCP or
dynamic host configuration protocol.
This is the default setting for most
operating systems and it makes it very
easy to obtain an IP address and
immediately connect and use the network.
If a DHCP server is not available and a
manual or static IP address has not been
configured on a workstation, then your
machine will decide to create its own IP
address based on APIPA. This stands for
automatic private IP addressing. You
might also hear this referred to as a
link local address because this is a
type of IP address that can only
communicate on its local network. If
you're assigned an API IPA address,
you're not able to communicate across
the internet. One way to tell if you've
been assigned an AP IPA address is to
look at the IP address on your
workstation and if it is between the
range of
169.254.1.0 through 169.254.254
254.255, then you have been assigned an
API IPA address. There may be certain
situations where you always want a
device to have exactly the same IP
address every time you turn it on. We
refer to these as static addresses.
These might be manually configured on a
local machine or you might have that
particular device configured with an
address reservation in your DHCP server.
To be able to configure the static
address manually, you'll need to know
information such as your IP address,
subnet mask, and default
gateway. Those three values are the most
important when you're configuring TCP IP
on a device. That IP address is a unique
identifier that's specific to that
computer. A subnet mask helps define
what IP subnet this device is connected
to. And a default gateway is a device
that is routing your local network
traffic onto networks that are outside
of your local subnet. You're also often
configuring a DNS or domain name
services IP address. This is the device
that converts that fully qualified
domain name to an IP address. So instead
of having to remember what the IP
address is of my web server, you simply
type into your browser
www.professormemeser.com and behind the
scenes, this DNS server is able to
convert that fully qualified domain name
to its appropriate IP address. And we've
already seen that many devices will
obtain all of this information from a
centralized database of IP addresses
called the DHCP server or dynamic host
configuration protocol server. One
interesting address that's important to
know for IP version 4 is the loop back
address of your computer. The loop back
address is
127.0.0.1. Although technically it's any
IP address that's on that 127 network.
This is an address that defines the
internal IP address of your computer.
It's on every single computer and it's a
way that you can confirm that the IP
stack of your device is working
properly. At home, you probably have a
single DHCP server and it's probably
integrated into an existing internet
router. If you're in a business
environment, it's common to have
multiple DHCP servers because that is
such an important service to have
available. We want to be sure there is
redundancy if we happen to lose one of
those servers. But there may be times
when you want to configure your device
to use DHCP. But if a DHCP server is
unavailable, you don't want your
computer configuring itself with an
APIPA address. Instead, you want to use
a predefined alternate configuration.
And that is one that you would add to a
separate tab inside of Windows. You can
make this a separate automatic IP
address for DHCP or you can manually
configure all of the settings under that
alternate
configuration. Let's add an alternate
configuration to my computer. I'm going
to go into the control panel and I'm
going to choose the options for network
and sharing center. Inside of the
network and sharing center, I'll choose
the options to change adapter settings.
You can see I have a single Ethernet
adapter in this device. And if I right
mouse click, I can choose the option for
properties. Inside of the properties,
you can see that there is an internet
protocol version 4 available. And if I
choose the properties of that option,
you'll see that a manual IP address
configuration is currently selected with
10.110.102. It would be much easier if I
could have this device automatically
obtain an IP address. And if DHCP is not
available, I could have an alternate
configuration for the
10.110.102. So if we click the option to
obtain an IP address automatically, the
alternate configuration tab is now
available. If we click alternate
configuration, we can now set a user
configured IP address. For example, this
might be where I add my
10.110.102 IP address. And that will be
my alternate configuration if a DHCP
server is not available. We'll now add
in the subnet mask for all of these,
which is
255.25.25.0. And the default gateway is
10.1.10.1. We can also specify DNS
servers in here in the alternate
configuration. For example, I might want
to put quad
9. And that might be the default I would
have for my alternate configuration. We
can click okay and click okay again. And
now we're back to where we started. This
is now going to check the configuration
of the settings that we just added. It's
going to change this to a DHCP
configuration and it's going to include
the alternate configuration in the case
that DHCP is not available. Now, if we
go back and look at the properties of
that configuration, it now has the IP
address automatic configuration and
includes the alternate configuration
inside of Windows.